وسط سحب من الرمل المتطاير يتدرب
الاماراتيين المشاركون في سباق التحمل على
خيولهم في الصحراء خارج اماره دبي وتمتطي
هذه الخيول مجموعه من الفتيات احداهن هي
شمس الشمس ذات العش ربيعا والتي تتدرب
للمشاركه في سباق خير لها بطول 160
كيلومترا هذه الرياضه تمثل ثقافتنا
ولطالما كانت هذه الرياضه الشعبيه حكرا
على الرجال فقط لكن بعض التغيرات طرات
حديثا كانت الفكره السائده هي عدم قدره
النساء على امتطاء الخيل لكن الان يمكنك
رؤيه العديد منم اصبحن يمارسن هذه
الرياضه وفي اسطبل مجاور يمتلكه شقيق حاكم
اماره دبي الشيخ حمدان يقوم مدير السباق
عل المري بتدريب 15 فتاه تحضيرا لسباق
التحمل وهو عدد كبير اذا ما قرن بامارات
اخرى في البلاد يجب ان تتصف بالصبر لان
السباق يمتد لمسافات وساعات طويله تتدرب
هؤلاء الفتيات كل يوم ويدن في حلبه سباق
بطول 60 كيلومترا في نهايه كل اسبوع
ويعتبر علي المري هذه الفتاه النجمه
الرئيسيه اذ فازت فاطمه بعده سباقات مع
اكبر المتسابقين وهي لا تزال بعمر ال
عاما احتلت المراتب الثانيه والثالثه في ق
كبيره ضد منافسيها الرجال ومرت بالكثير
لتنال كاس سباق تحمل ركوب الخيل
للسيدات كنت اسمع الصراخ وكنت انا نفسي
اصرخ لكن حاولت في الوقت ذاته ان اركز على
الفوز بذلك
السباق في هذا اليوم يفاجئ علي كلا من
فاطمه وشركتها في السباق دانا بجوائز
لفوزه في سباقه الاخير سيارتان جديدتان
اما مريم ذات الع عاما فلم تفز بسياره بعد
لكنها تحاول اللحاق بالاخرين في السباق
لطالما اخبرت عائلتي برغبتي في المشاركه
بسباقات التحمل فانا احب الصحراء واحب
المساحات المفتوحه واحب التحدي والسرعه
التي يمثلهما سباق التحمل فازت مريم
بالمرتبه الثانيه في كاس الامارات للتحمل
بطول 120 كيلومترا وحازت بذلك على
الاحترام وعلى رميه في المياه قدمها اليها
زملاؤها المتسابقون
مدربهم يقول ان النساء بالاخص مناسبات
لسباقات
التحمل هناك فرق بين امتطاء الرجال
والنساء للاحصنه النساء بشكل عام لطيفات
وعندما يسحبن اللجام فانهن يحدد مدى سرعه
الحصان اما الرجال فيشد اللجام بقوه اكبر
وبالتالي قد يؤدي ذلك الى فقدان الطاقه
وانهاك الحصان القوه بكاملها هنا ويمكن
للنساء مضاهاتها والتغلب على المشاركين
الرجال نحب هزيمه
الرجال افضل اللحظات عندما ترتسم نظره على
وجوههم حين نسبق الى خط
النهايه هل يحصل ذلك في الغالب نعم كثيرا
مع
فاطمه من الجيد معرفه ادراكهم لقوه المراه
وقدرتها على تحدي
الرجال حتى اقوى المتسابقين يحتاجون
للراحه فهذه الخيمه التقليديه مع كوب من
الشاي هي الطريقه التي ترتاح فيها هؤلاء
المتسابقات بعد التدريب المطول في الصحراء
l